[Music]
uh uh don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings bab
Don't Be Afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey bab hey bab
hey bab
hey I can't stop stop the beat I won't
stop stop stop the
beat
everybody move your feet and feel
United hey
bab yes we're back baby
back yes guys girls others we are back
we're here this is the first we call it
you know PHP post homeless pimp post
homeless pimp this is postom he's out
there somewhere he's looking at
somewhere out there he's looking at the
same Moon as us homeless pimp is looking
at the same mov as us he has he is he is
alive and well he's alive and well he's
he's just setting around the country on
different projects yes he's got a very
he's got irons in the fire and God bless
him but so we still have to have fun
over here we do and we and we love to
have fun and uh we we have changed
Studios which people know because the
last episodes were were here as well M
but what what did we mention I don't
know if we mentioned this this is the
new space but this is just a temporary
setup and we're doing a huge overhaul
yep and uh and we're going to have a
completely different scene going we
talked about it we're going to go over
there and we're going to have that
behind us and we're going to get we're
going to actually really get like you
know rate rate you could rate our studio
yes we'd love that we have some ideas
that when we're ready to share them
we'll put them out we love some fan
input on them and maybe even let the
fans decide what certain things they'd
like to in the studio that might be nice
you know and I know some people have
already said cuz I've talked about it
you know on Instagram we cannot we have
no way of getting Kane to knock his
ashes or body dead body in the studio
legally we can't do it legally yeah but
there is a plan in place uh a nighttime
Mission if you will to maybe extract
something illegally yes if you see
salari in Japan or in the East Asian
vicinity we know that yes we're doing
shows but it's a cover for we're going
to get Kan and bring her back Wednesday
in case things go south we like no this
is just I just went to mass yes um it
would be nice to have her to sprinkle
them in here it'd be nice to have Kan
Tanaka's body with us each and every
episode not even heres her body her body
i' love to have her body her bones here
could you taxid
Hume that's a good qu I'm listen I know
the process you can is it legal that's
another question didn't we look at those
crazy funerals where like like the guy
was dead but just like sitting on a
chair with his so they do do it they do
do it maybe we can crowdfund from our
from our faithful we crowdfund money and
we make a we make an offer to the family
of tanak Kane's family I would love to
and then maybe we get her on loan like a
museum yes you know what I mean she's on
loan from the K Tanaka estate yes and we
just put her right here sitting here
legs crossed with a funny smile right
and then uh we have her like every every
quarter every quarter every other
quarter I would love and I would pay
good money for that um to have Kan
Tanaka's body and I have two things to
say first I'd like to introduce uh our
new producer his name is Steve Chone
reron earthtone right is it e r t h o n
e yes sir that
name it was just uh I don't know it just
uh where did Earth Tone come from what
does it mean you know I wanted to sell
like uh t-shirts back in the day and
that was that was what I was going to
call the the like the T-shirt compan
like a hippie dippy thing no no I I do
like Earth Tones like those colors who
doesn't really I mean now some fun facts
about Steve Chone reron is one fellas
yes he is single two an unbelievable
drummer he he's he's fantastic on the
drums he's got a special talent he used
to work at the Sam Ash down in Los
Angeles speaking of Ash Guitar Center
Guitar Center guitar center but speaking
of Ashes speaking of Ash Sam ashes Sam
ashes work at the Guitar Center down in
Los Angeles and one of your everyday
customers was it Charles Barkley who was
one of the ones that you really bonded
with Kenley Jansen Kenley Jansen from
the pitcher from the uh LA Dodgers at
the time really took a good liking to
Steve and and and I was thinking that a
nice way to incorporate Steve into the
show is maybe at some point we could
have him bring in his drum kid and drum
set and do a drum solo on on the show
with us how do we not do it to start we
should we should have we should have
been like hold on we have to introduce
you to someone and just let him solo
first and then be like it speaks for
itself yes yeah we'll do we'll do that
we'll make believe that one of the
episodes is his first episode later on
we'll just all play pretend and then
this this and so Steve welcome to the
show and and I think it's going to be
great okay do you own any sunflower
pants I don't have any sunflower pant
we're get sunflower pants sunflower
pants um Steve so we we Steve has been
on I don't know if taste buds came out
yet the first taste buds but we've had
our intro up with Steve on tastebuds he
is the new in-house noes resident
producer he's got a a million dollar
smile he's a sweetheart of a guy he is a
he was a longtime listener and and
Enthusiast of our podcast and of the
network he used to have hair his hair
used to have hair down in the top of his
ass crack too no bringing pictures right
away I oh you have them okay I donated
it all right let's get those pict you
donated your hair yeah what' you donate
to this is the kind of this is the kind
of kid we're talking about here great
Steve Steve Chone Maron yeah children
children with cancer little a little
girl got my hair amazing you like a
little girl now that I'm looking at you
now all of a sudden she's doing like
sick drumming solos she got your powers
yes I would love to see like what what
you could do on the drums so you want to
can do you have like a small kit like or
an electric kit or what do you do uh
yeah I got a small kit um well I have
two I have a regular size kit more like
the rock sizes both both lwig drums um
and then the other one's a little bit
smaller and also I know that you're a
funk drummer yes which is you know for
me that's my that's my favorite you know
what you know what I think if if he
plays his cards right you know he's
going to wind up and Le Joker's Cruise
2025 oh you play your cards right that's
up this is coming back we just had the
cruise last week the reason I was late
today was because I was making a
schedule for that cruise it took two
hours it's hard it's hard oh no listen
four days of programming with like 90 a
it's not easy and I I I would have went
I would have went on the cruise but I
think I'm in Nashville I'm in you are I
had asked you for this year doing no
press thing you couldn't do it D roza
was on it the by the way the cruise was
amazing amazing D roza fell overboard
but we hooked him right back in we look
for a squiggly tail in the water yeah
just look for it in the news he fell
overboard and uh yes well so that was
the first thing I want to introduce
Steve and then I the second thing is I
wanted to ask is where do you get the
nerve who do you think you are coming
into this studio with a mustache you
have now grown a mustache like your
Kevin Coster on Yellowstone and I want
to know where you have the balls to come
in there and not only not send me
pictures of it before not say a goddamn
word you come in here you lose 40 lbs
and you have a mustache and I want to
know what's
happening I want to know why you look
better than I've ever seen you look in
your in your life oh that's so nice of
you to say I don't believe that but not
that I don't believe it from you I don't
even believe that for me but um I I I
put on about another few pounds I lost
it for the special and I put on a few
because it's the holidays it's the high
it's the high holies and I've been
eating pastries out the yin-yang and a
lot of pizza as a matter of fact you
just ordered two pies to the studio Happ
so uh but I by the way it's it's we are
when you're in ordinary time the
Catholics we call this time period
ordinary time you can be ordinary you
don't have to be losing weight or you
just be ordinary I'm being ordinary
right now let's see that might be them
right now yes but I will say that um the
uh uh you the the the the mustache look
and the the way you look I like it oh
thanks so what I did was I shaved clean
shaving for the first time in 13 years
this is just growing back now a few days
ago I I I went clean like you didn't
have a you you a baby's ass on your face
I went skin to I went buzzer to skin you
did it or the barber did I did it and
then I just had the mustache on New
Year's Eve I was just a Mustachio old
man that's it you post pcks or no no I
didn't actually but but but it's still
playing like it's just the mustache it
doesn't look like I have the first thing
I noticed when you walked in I said this
guy this guy's full mustache and there's
nothing I can do about it full must when
I was little when we were little the
mustache and just the mustache was a big
thing sure in the 70s and ' 80s and I
would look at guys and say that's an old
man and I never understood the concept
of just the mustache it felt very like
uh I don't know I just I was like that's
that never going to be me and then I hit
a certain age and I've been Desiring
just the mustache for a very long time
right it looks good but uh but I didn't
do it but yeah it could be Fuller here
and less here maybe one day we'll get
there but it'll grow it'll grow in and I
think that you you're you what I what
I'll say about you is lately you've been
taking chances you've been taking
chances and that's a good thing yeah and
um and I like the way it looks and uh
and and and the the whole cowboy thing
the mustache and that's coming back what
let me ask you a question right now ask
me too what's comeback what's had a
bigger comeback yeah in the world yeah
than country music and New Balance
sneakers name two things that have had a
bigger comeback than country music and
New Balance sneakers okay let's think
all right please
uh who's had a big comeback I don't know
I mean everybody's listening the country
and wearing new Bal sneakers now and
then 15 years ago nobody was doing that
neither of those neither yeah I think
mus is the biggest biggest music in the
country it is number one by they did it
right they named it after the country
yes you know what I mean but I do you do
you partake in country I I I had it
until call two three years ago and now I
really love Luke Holmes Morgan Wallen uh
uh um uh Chris Stapleton I love these I
know my Dad L likes country and he's
always singing Tennessee whiskey that's
good
Vince spit everywhere I love it Morgan
Walling he can do a run that guy you
know what a run is when they go like
like the run in the voice like when
they're
like yeah yeah yeah yeah he can do that
guy's Chris steton Chris Stapleton is
Fant expecting he that's that's he's got
a velvety well that's real talent like
guys like that like I did I ever tell
you the time I met Ed shearan twice I
told you about this already so I did how
did you not tell me you met Ed Sheeran
here we go 2012 I'm at this is the this
is the guy that's dating Travis Kelce
yes okay so I I I'm in it's called it
was called The V Festival not named
after Vena who still on works for the
show by the way just not here today not
it was the V Festival I think it was
name for Virgin uh you know music or
Airlines or whatever out in um England I
was in I think I was doing the one in
leads right oh I love leads love leads I
had a wild Knight out in leads one time
you had a wild Knight in leads I did
wonderful you going to tell us about it
I mean I just went to a bar they played
a lot of soul music we got drunk and
party with the crowd and it was a lot of
fun I was with burn it was one was doing
the your your UK tour UK tour yeah shout
out leads shout out leads um so I I go
out there I'm doing the V Festival I'm
you know no name comedian doing the back
tent right I did the show there was you
know 10 people walking through nobody
cared it was like you know just a cool
opportunity to get out there so anyway
where you eat like the little commissary
they have for the performers it's all
musicians and everybody is just kind of
there sure yeah so I'm there sitting
there and I'm eating sweet potato fries
like you do like I do I got to I got a
bat of sweet potato fries here and then
I got a bat of ketchup there and I'm
dipping the sweet potato fries in the
ketchup England one in England that's
what you do one in leads so I'm eating
it and then a guy sits down he says oh
is somebody sitting here I said no uh
sits down across and then he goes uh I
look at him and he he looked like um you
know yeah Ronald McDonald yeah he looks
small he look like a potato like just
like a small and kind of like you know
just kind of like tucked in by himself
you know had long red hair and I said um
I said I said oh you know P I'm I'm
Chris I'm doing comedy goes hi I'm Ed I
do music and I was like oh awesome and
he goes uh he goes yeah he goes are you
from the Estates I said yeah he was like
he was like oh cool he was like yeah I
love it here I was like yeah no it's
awesome and he was like sweet potato
fries huh I said yeah I I like them I
dip them in ketchup all the time and he
goes I've never seen anybody do that I
was like really interesting Where What
Where where are you from like what rock
you you never seen any dip sweet potato
fries and ketchup but anyway that's what
I remember about him and he says he says
okay he says I'm know I'm going to go
play at whatever 10 4 and I was like all
right and then he goes you know I had
another show and then about call it two
hours later I hear this like Angelic
beautiful voice singing and I see a man
this is man I see flocks of people cuz
he didn't he wasn't a star not seagull
people actual people okay I see flocks
of people coming in a herd to stop and
look at this guy's tent and start
listening to his music and I looked I
was like oh that's the guy I was talking
to that's a sweet potato guy and I
remember in my I remember then in my
head or like whatever like to myself I
was calling him in my head he looked
like a little fry guy himself with he
did I was calling him sweet potato Ed
that's what I was calling him in my
head and then you didn't wait this is
before he had a hit that you knew of you
didn't Place him his no his voice was
incredible oh but he didn't have a hit
yet he did not have a hit so you met him
before he was him to us or maybe had a
small hit in the UK but he was not the
she that we all know and love today he
he wasn't he didn't have your bodies in
Wonderland nothing like that and then I
saw him and then I and then and then I
remember seeing him and cuz he had such
a distinct look and then it was like 6
months later he blew up and I was like I
that was sweet potato Ed wow and I know
that if I ever met him or talked to him
he would not remember the story but I
remember he'll remember you cuz you he
never saw anyone dip sweet Po in ketchup
and it by the way what do you dip them
in I dip him in ketchup a lot of kids a
lot of people do a lot of kids do
ketchup and Mayo a lot of people now
will do in ranch um what do you do reron
sweet potato yeah Agave this is what
we're talking about with this kid you
see the BR he's bringing stuff to the
table immediately okay I never heard of
anyone dipping anything in theave never
mind sweet potato fries you know I only
do that cuz Trader Joe's one time I went
in there and they had that up front that
was like they hit you as soon as you
came in and they were trying to sell the
agave syrup and they would dipping the
sweet potato fries they know what
they're doing over there tjs do you know
what else you know what else you then
they got to you they got you to purchase
that
and now you do at home well guess what
do you know what else is another
unbelievable fact about St reron only a
master uh uh drums man he makes coffee
he has a he has a a a $11,000 plus
coffee setup in his house he can make
you any cup of coffee espresso Americano
homemade not a Cura cup he will make it
like you're in a random coffee shop in
downtown Pittsburgh you got yourself a
machine yeah what are you working with
no but it's more than that it's are you
working with an exotic Italian one or
you got a brevel i i i with a brevel so
it's uh I have a brevel he told me to
get a brevel yeah most of the stuff I
have is by this company called fellow
fellow yeah and um it's more the rig I
have is geared more towards like uh
manual right words he could tell he
could tell you're not you think who you
are you saying I got a brabel he's like
the rig like do you use a consumer
machine or the rig you have the rig yeah
what do you got going on over there so
uh he knows all the terms yeah well it's
so you ever a Bist no but during the
pandemic I I guess I wow I became one he
cut his hair off and be and started
making coffe yeah I I diverted from the
sourdough loaf route I know a lot of
people went and you know made they got
their starters on yeah a lot of people
did make sourdough why did you know that
how did you know that was that a by the
way sourdough is a great bread it's a
fermented food we're going to talk a lot
about fermented foods today I want to
talk to you guys a lot about the gut
microbiome and and what fermented foods
you should be eating and sough bread is
one of them everything thoughts and ends
at the gut I know this for a fact and I
still haven't put into practice yet but
I had a conversation about 3 or 4 days
ago and I'm ready to do it these socks
by the way these brown socks somebody uh
came up to me and asked me if I burn my
feet because they look like with
sneakers on it looks like this is the
color of my
skin me
too they thought I charred mine you're
in
Blackfoot um so what's your coffee drink
of choice uh pourover I just drink a
black coffee pourover style jeez so he's
also a purist dude when I him and I went
to Detroit and we went into this really
nice coffee shop and he could taste the
Integrity of The Bean soon as he took a
sip said these are low Integrity beans I
took the I took the coffee I threw off
the wall
we that's the name of the episode low
Integrity be integ low Integrity be
Steve is it's one man like you know you
you get to talk to him you get to talk
to him and you're like oh I love I I
mean we only met recently like this
because we had to do the you know we we
met we then we did taste buds by the end
of the day yeah I know know all about
the guy he's great guy he's a great guy
he's got a great great disposition
unbelievable disposition and he and you
know he knew the only thing I love more
than state capitals and Puerto Rican
people is ice coffee black you know what
this man gets me for Christmas you know
what this man comes in gets me for
Christmas black iced coffee not only
that in machine of contraption where I
can now grind and make my own homemade
ice coffee he brought you the means he
brought me the means means to the beans
the means to the beans which is which is
is is is is a close number two for
episode title wow I I I uh cortado is my
thing Cort Cort tell us Cort so you got
you got you got your L latte okay then
you got your flat white I'm asking you
then you got your cappuccino then your C
isn't it the same thing but just
different levels of milk see that I
don't I'm not well versed in like the
espresso style okay okay oh you're a
coffee guy oh oh it's different to you
yeah yeah cuz my know but my brel is my
brevel espresso or coffee beans well
it's coffee beans but it's it's grinding
it for espresso drinks what's the
difference tell us what the difference
is an espresso bean and a coffee bean
the same exact thing see that they're
different beans I don't know I guess the
espresso might be roasted a little bit
longer I like to do espresso beans me
too yeah yeah um no yeah but but the the
only thing the biggest difference as far
as I know is the the grind size espresso
you grind it's very very fine yeah and
then something like a cold brew is all
the way in the other spectr and be Co
you ready for the coffee I've been
making that that my family at home
really loves now the brand you ready for
this the brevel machine i' I've created
my own thing it's called the Chrissy
it's really just the about the grind
time I grind the beans a little bit more
what's it it tampering tampering yeah is
it tampering Tamp tamping so I Tamp it
down I give it a nice Tamp I put it in
the thing I go the the the two pores I
get it to about halfway full then what I
do is I fro the milk you got a fro on
your got that fro fro the milk I fro
that milk I don't really do but I got it
when I froth the milk you ready when as
the milk is frothing you know what I
throw in there honey and cinnamon I pour
honey cinnamon milk into the cough Stir
It Up honey cinnamon milk I in while the
milk is frothing you put cinnamon and
honey in on your own exactly as they are
pure yes you don't have a honey cinnamon
milk no that'd be that'd be outrageous
if they made a honey cinnamon milk I
mean that sounds great though actually
but but and then I pour that milk that
warm milk honey and coffee honey honey
cinnamon and froth milk into the coffee
family loves it I got the kids drinking
it no way I got the kids drinking it how
do you know what portion of how much to
Honey to put in it's all I I try to
connect I it's all feeling it's all
feeling you know so what do you do you
just put cuz you don't want to go
overboard on the honey no is it a hint
of honey it's a spoonful of Honey a
teaspoon of of Blackberry Farm pure
honey and that's for everybody's the
whole you making a pod or you making
these individuals no you make individual
cuffs myself and Jazz we drink the the
the coffee but then the kids the kids I
give them the milk and the kidss they're
looking forward to honey cinnamon milk
which we thought was a healthier option
than chocolate milk all day every day I
mean kids teeth are going to fall out of
their heads so we go honey cinnamon milk
and the kids love it you ready for this
these are the breakfast now honey
cinnamon milk for the kids and then we
give them a a cinnamon flavored rice
cake with almond butter and banana on it
and the side of berries can't go wrong
and they love it they love it and
secretly eating healthy not really
secret it's right out in the open it's
right in the open unless it's too stupid
to realize right because I think we
spoke about this did we speak about this
about the gut microbiome how about the
scientist Dr Pooh did we talk about Dr
Pooh uh I think I would have remembered
Dr po okay so I want to talk to you for
a minute about Dr Pooh no we speaking of
honey but no Dr Pooh Google Dr Pooh is
it pu or po I'm hoping po it is Dr it's
not yeah what oh Dr Pooh is just the
name of a company that's not a real guy
do Dr poo what's his real name Dr poo uh
podcast with Steven um with yeah Steven
yes oh Dr Pooh is someone's nickname
though yes where oh yeah here we go the
number the number one Pooh and gut
scientist this guy this guy I watched a
life-changing podcast wouldn't you want
to be number two though I I'm do I'm
going to keep doing funny little CPS I
love it so what they talked about s what
Dr Pooh talked about the I think it's
it's gut health and on Instagram but
this guy he has got like a very hard to
pronounce last name if your poo looks
like so basically he was saying about
Yap poo and B basically about you who
you are who
who who who Z salano is is you are your
gut microbiome so your personality you
are you literally everything right
everything whatever your personality is
whatever you're craving it is your gut
microb we are a super organism what the
hell's going on now
hello the food is downstairs what
meaning meaning what meaning they're not
going to come up we got to go
down okay can you tell them we'll come
right down all right okay by so we don't
know how to work the new intercom thing
to let people Buzz them into the
building yet so the food we ordered is
outside right now so what do we got to
pause do we got to stop down for one
second all we'll stop down for one
second you got to go put on shoes all
right sorry ass man are you looking for
a super offer for Super Bowl 58 I know I
am yeah so draftking sports book has you
covered new customers can bet on the big
game and turn five bucks into 200
instantly in bonus bets that's amazing
it is what do you have to do you have to
download the draftking sports app now I
just started chewing a tum I'll I'll say
it then you download the draftking
sports book app now use code hey babe
new customers can get five bucks to get
200 instantly in bonus bets bonus only
on draftking sports book an official
sports betting partner of Super Bowl 58
with code hey babe the crown is yours
gambling problem call one800 Gambler or
in West Virginia you go to ww. 1800
gambler. net in New York you can call
8778 Hope NY or text Hope n which is
4673 69 in con concut guess what they
got help available for problem gambling
you call
9777 or visit ccpg dog please play
respons on behalf of Casino in Resort in
Kansas every I mean shout out booill
Casino Resort in Kansas God bless him 21
plus age varies by jurisdiction void in
Ontario which is interesting but we'll
we'll we'll deal with it hang tight for
another couple bonus bets expire 168
hours oh my God issuance see
dk.com foot for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming resources that's really all you
got to know that's it all right baby
hellofresh America's number one meal kit
what is it what is it if you hellofresh
first of all I mean if you don't know
about this now I'd like to come over and
give you a slap give you a little
something over here and a a little
something over there you get farm fresh
pre-portion ingredients and season rep
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip the trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable that's why it's
America's number one meal and you know
we use it we shout it at every week I
swear to you it's taught me how to cook
yep I make I use the 15minute recipes
when I'm in a rush they have they change
their their recipes seasonally which is
amazing cheaper than going to the
grocery store by the way it's a family
thing now too yes it's all about family
hellofresh they come with as I said the
arm fresh package ingredients everything
arrives pre-portion right to your door
for less there's no wasted food you
don't worry about meal planning anymore
you ditch that you ditch those Blues
hellofresh does everything for you
breakfast they say is the most important
meal of the day and guess who agrees
hell fresh I was going to guess Hesh
they agree in fact this is what we when
when we talk about this company
sometimes we are flabbergasted perplexed
we're astounded by how they even make
money because listen to this promo the
deal's all hot like fire listen to this
all subscribers free breakfast for Life
how they're giving everybody free
breakfast go to hellofresh.com heyab
free and use code heyab free for free
breakfast for life and that's however
long you live one breakfast item per box
while subscription is active however
long you live as long as subscription is
active exactly that's mean if if you
really take care of yourself and you
know you don't eat twoo high fatty foods
and you keep your cardiovascular good
and you keep subscribe to like 104 you
got free breakfast to 104 that's it
that's free breakfast for life at
hellofresh.com heyab free with code hey
babf free Hello fresh America's number
one meal kit folks this episode brought
to you by better help thank you to the
good folks over there at betterhelp for
helping us with all our mental health
needs man I mean listen the world is
what it is right now okay yeah so
sometimes we all got to talk to someone
a common misconception like about
relationships even is that they have to
be easy to be right that's no best
relation can be difficult where both
people uh put in the work and they make
them great all right the same thing with
yourself I'm saying that's what I'm
saying for real therapy can be a place
to work through the challenges you face
in all of your relationships including
ones with friends work significant other
or yourself if you're thinking of
starting a therapy give better help a
try it's done entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule all you do fill out a
brief questionnaire get match with the
license therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge and
maybe look maybe it's not for you but
I'm someone who practices and I am
someone who uh who I I I preach about it
I think it's it's the gym for your mind
I go a couple times a week and uh try it
what do you have to lose right
especially if you've been thinking about
it become your own soulmate whether
you're looking for one or not visit
betterhelp.com heyab today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com
heyab babe V VOR I told you about this I
love this when you travel if you have to
use VOR I have used it you have I did I
used it to go on a walking tour a whole
ghost tour in uh New Orleans yeah VI
tour it's the best you can use them
right here in New York City I've been on
Plenty of Walker tours all over the
world 300,000 bookable travel
experiences in over 190 countries wow
there's that many countries yes there's
so many of them I'll name them all
another time okay they offer everything
from simple tours to Extreme Adventures
and all the niche little interesting
stuff in between VOR is the place to go
to book memorable travel experiences I
mean listen vur it's one of those things
where any time I've went on a a trip
I've looked on I've gotten there I've
put VOR in I've said tours near me and
100 tours come up it's amazing cuz you
don't have to worry about what's where
it's like it's the one source for it all
so you can go on vacation and be like
just look ahead of time and that's it
it's a one source in a way I kind of
feel bad it kind of almost cuts out
travel agents cuz I'm like I can just
book my own trip on the apps and then go
on VI tour and they'll tell me exactly
what to do and every tour I've wenton in
has been a five out of five home run of
a tour yeah the ghost one thank you
because it reinforced my feelings that I
do not believe in them there you go
you're staying up at night with
heartburn fire TOS travel experiences
have millions of real traveler reviews
so you have the information you need to
book for the best activities for your
trip and they re that I look at those
reviews all the time VI tour the trip
reviews it's real people who did the
tour and it helps you you know that's
actually the absolute best part of it uh
flexibility support all the time with
free cancellation payment options and
24/7 service download the vator app now
and use code vur10 for 10% off your
first booking in the app the app uh over
300,000 travel experiences uh you
remember yes do more with VOR yes one
app over 300,000 traveling sorry I
didn't have my glasses but do more with
VOR like you said right back got the
food so the gut microbiome from what Dr
Pooh is saying the gut microbiome who's
got it's gut health MD on on IG I I is
he that poo right there that's Dr Pooh
okay that's Dr poo poo I pict the gut
health MD go follow on Instagram I
pictured
someone but that's only because I
thought Dr Pooh was pu at first it's p o
okay so Dr Pooh said about the gut
microbiome everything everything he's
got a book I think his book's called
fiber fued or he's got he's got a couple
of books go just go Google this guy this
guy came out of nowhere I heard him on
this podcast Steven Bartlett podcast
which I really really like and Dr Pooh
you know I've been listening a lot to
like the gut health microbiome and and
all that stuff and they're saying that
you have like trillions and trillions of
microbi of like little microbiomes in
your gut that dictate your whole life
they dictate who you are they dictate
your personality your Cravings your this
your that and like for example when you
drink a Diet Coke okay yes it's got zero
calories right he said you know we're
focused a little bit on calories
calories calories yes yes it has zero
calories sure but the aspiran and other
chemicals in these like you know
artificial sweetener sodas and Foods
literally change or gut microbiome where
like Technically when you drink a Diet
Coke you're a completely different
person you're not the natural person
you're supposed to be you drank a Diet
Coke your gut microbiome has changed you
into somebody else you have a different
personality I'll slap someone right in
the teeth you slap yeah absolutely and I
could and I don't have to be feel guilty
is that what you're saying yes cuz it's
the it's the DC that made me do it you
you should be able to get out of M
murders if you killed someone in a d
Coke like I didn't how did I do that
just for the taste of it I can promise
you that I just drank a Diet Coke I have
proof I have the receipt so it it re
jiggers everything in there and then all
of a sudden your normal functionality is
different and that manifest itself in a
possibly a different what temperament
personality what do like for example
like you know you drink a Diet Coke your
gut M yes you have zero calories but
then your gut microbiome May that's may
start craving sugar and high carb foods
because it's like literally not who you
are like you were on the straight and
arrow on a diet drinking water shelters
and you know high fiber foods and now
you have to die Coke and all of a sudden
it changed you into this other guy going
to be next thing you know an hour later
you're eating a candy bar and and all
that and the cat you're not texting
people back I'm not texting people back
you're not cing your toenails anymore
exactly I'm I'm I'm like you know taking
the lord's name in vain anything
anything anything so all from Diet Coke
all from Diet Coke so he's just saying
like paying attention to you and one of
the best things you can do
to to make sure your gut microbiome
stays health drink regular Coke if
you're going to do it do that limit
alcohol which we know but even he says
like he drinks alcohol like we're human
beings but the other one is fermented
foods sauerkraut homemade sauerkraut
okay I'm talking about get a cabbage
chop it up put it in a mason jar put
some brine water in there put some you
know vinegar let it sit for a week in a
dark damn place sauerkraut fermented
food yogurt fermented food um things
with live and active cultures that's
what they want fermentation take a
Probot yeah probiotic Prebiotic pre or
Pro maybe do some and post they got
Prebiotic probiotics postbiotics oh wow
yeah so this guy goes wild and you know
it's all about he said guy goes wild on
biotics wild he said what the best thing
you can do from the studies the studies
that that that they've seen is if you
can eat 30 different types of plants a
week you're in good shape 30 different
varieties of plants a week I I I thought
there was maybe three varieties total
he's saying 30 flowers there's weeds
that's it but he said there's a lot more
legumes nuts seeds I I would I would
assume fruit counts laguma beach laguma
beach yeah he said the assault on fruit
is nuts I mean there is an outright
assault on fruit and how people are
saying fruit's not good for you it's
high in sugar he said but the type of
there are studies that show if you just
eat fruit you reverse your diabetes that
The Assault The Assault on fruit he said
is is wild he doesn't know who started
the assault on fruit I don't know who
started the assault on fruit but there
is an assault on fruit and he said that
you you know like give your kids give
your body fruit eat fruit all you got to
do is eat fruit and you're good eat
fruit and drink Coke that's it wow and
you're good and your gut microbiome is
good so what do we do here how how long
will it take me to transform if I really
want to he said you could start
transforming your gut microbiome will
start to it'll react to anything you put
in it so like you start you eat a you
eat a whole you eat a bush of kale and
handfuls of blueberries your gut
microbiome starts to then become that
guy oh kale blueberry guy you know what
I got next thing you know you're a
farmer I know and I will I I've been you
know you said something and it sounded
appealing we should start eating things
in bushels yes you know what I mean not
enough things are done in bushels no you
know what I mean a bush is a great word
what do we have bushels of apples yeah I
don't know is it a bushel of kale I I
what what comes in bushels a bushel of a
bushel of apples no Bush did you hear
think I love you a bushel and the peek
what's that mean no yeah bushel and the
peek is like a never heard that saying
I've loved you a bushel and AEK yeah
bushel and a pek what's a bushel things
that come in bushel a bushel is an
imperial and US customary unit of volume
based upon an earlier measure of dry
capacity the old bushel is equal to two
Kennings which is an obsolete term four
pecs or eight dry gallons so a bushel is
equal to eight dry gallons so a PEC is
equal to two dry gallons stay with us
don't change that dial and was mostly
used for agricultural products such as
wheat in modern usage the volume is
nominal with bushels denoting a mass
defined differently for each commodity
the name bushel is also used to
translate similar units in other
measurement systems right wow it was
originally used for the container itself
and later a unit of measurement the name
comes from the old French B meaning
little box right and May further derive
from old friendship Boise meaning Idaho
meaning little butt little bushel means
little butt okay so a bushel has now
become what we want it to be but a
bushel used to be eight dry gallons
eight dry so you ate eight dry gallons
of kale your stomach's like something's
different something's different yeah um
all right but what's a PEC a bushel and
a PEC Google four pecs what do pecs mean
click on pecs right there see four pecs
or eight dry gallons yeah right there
boom boom a PEC a PEC is an imperial and
United States customer unit of dry
volume equivalent to two dry gallons or
eight dry cords or 16 dry pints an
imperial PEC is equivalent to 9.09 lers
and a US customary PEC is equivalent to
8.81 lers well I'll tell you right now I
got two pecs across from me right now
that might as well be might as well be
four dry gallons I'll Peck everybody
yeah speaking of why they call pecs cuz
they have gallons of they hold gallons
of milk that must be the reason probably
that's it speaking of gallons of milk
have you ever have have you ever went to
see professional bull riding live and in
person the PBR I saw a rodeo okay I
don't think there were Bulls there I
think they were I don't think there were
Bulls there I got to go witness bull a
bull a bull I a bull I got to go witness
professional bull riding at Madison
Square Garden last weekend s let me tell
you something if we we always were on
the
I didn't get the call I I you get the
call you get the
[Music]
call I know I only I only had a couple
of seats all right I had to give it to
the kids I had to give it to the kids I
Buck off at the Garden that's what this
was called okay I literally s if cuz
there's been times where you and I have
questioned we've spoken about it we've
texted about it are we real men I can
tell you now definitively the answer is
we are not no after seeing what cowboys
yeah what what a real man is what a real
cowboy boy does and how they live their
life sir you absolutely must you must
promise me in case I never see you again
you must promise me that you will go see
professional bull riding and carry on my
good name throughout the stands I'll go
I I've always I almost went to the
running of the bulls in Pamplona Spain
one year right and it all fell through
it fell through but I but I was going to
wear a cute white outfit head to toe yes
and then just run for my life and and
just see what happened but uh someone
put the k on that but did they tie up
the nuts is that still do that's mean
they tie up the nuts but and people say
that's why they kick so much cuz their
nuts are get tied and then when that
they were giving us the tour and this
guy was great in front of my family he
goes let me ask you cuz you know my girl
asked she was like you know isn't that
like that's so mean like they must be
kicking cuz they get their nuts tied up
and then he said to me he said sir if I
tied up your nuts right now and my kids
are looking up at me he
said he said sure I I don't know what
results you want right now he said sir
if I tied up your nuts right now what
would you do I said I probably wouldn't
move he goes exactly the Bulls are not
kicking cuz their nuts are tied up the
Bulls he goes he goes if anything so why
am they kicking he said he said because
it's actually calming them down to to
tie their nuts up a little bit because
if they didn't he said if they didn't
tie their nuts up they would start
kicking people in the stands MSG would
just be done done wait wait wait you're
telling me they they tie up the nuts to
subdue them I think but but isn't tying
up the nuts still wrong why don't they
just not tie the nuts not subdue change
from 8 seconds to 16 seconds give you
double the seconds double the
nuts it's a good point yeah it's a good
point I never considered it what I will
tell you is though they were emphatic
and I do believe them but they were
emphatic about that they treat these
Bulls better than they treat their own
family the guy told me he said I feed
the Bulls before I feed my kids so they
love the Bulls so this whole idea the
blls are not getting treated right is a
myth but who's saying but but what do
they say for themsel well first of all
who ties the nuts and what's that
process can we google that how do you
tie a bull's nuts and is that a is that
is that a person is that the job you
know what I mean they have to be skilled
and that they get a high they get paid
for that cuz they know how to tie bull
nuts or is it like whoever's around be
like do me a favor grab that rope just
TI that those nuts real quick I'm going
to send this to you Steve but just so s
can see what I'm talking about I mean
look at look at this look at this oh
wait oh that oh look did you see Gore
look this was literally was alv uh so
they told so they told us you know they
tell the whole Arena they give you they
give the entire Arena like a little
background on Professional Bull Riders
right and they say the goal is is they
have to these are the best bull riders
in the world they have to stay on that
bull for eight seconds okay I mean they
did laser light shows and everything to
start they had the Cowboys in the ring
of fire they go 8 seconds they have to
stay on this bull these are the best
guys in the world they can all do it so
we are like pumped going crazy the very
first Cowboy out of the gate he has to
stay for 8 seconds look at
this no at 2.9 seconds and the answer
goes
no The Bu in with one move the guy just
fell off but look at this guy this guy
is the number one in the
world is that awesome yeah
look World Championship look at this guy
8 seconds and then watch oh my God
they're playing Sabotage by the DC boys
while it's happening yeah and then they
and then once you're done then you have
to get off and the Bulls going crazy and
it's these three guys from the National
Guard's job to calm the ball down but
you have to understand when you're on
the ball even if you make it to 8
seconds you still have to find a way to
get off the ball you have to Dismount
the ball and furthermore these guys do
It For the Love of the Game I respect
these guys like you can't imagine
because because if they do not ride the
bull they do not get paid so there was a
guy who on Friday night was on the bull
and then the bull kicked him in the face
and broke his jaw and he got on the bull
Saturday in excruciating pain there was
a guy who ripped the bicep off his arm
got on the bll the next day cuz if you
do not get on the bull you do not get
paid and it dude it was the most insane
thing I've ever seen in my life it's
wild that they're playing like they're
playing sabotage while he's on the bll
that C is going Buck Wild oh yeah and
the Bulls when they come out when they
come out of the of the cage sometimes
they throw the cowboy right into the
cage they'll throw a cowboy right into
the first row they don't care about and
these guys are unbeliev and by the way
you want to talk about a master class in
Chivalry every time they we met some of
the cowboys after the event they would
shake my hand when Jasmine or my
daughters were there they would take
their out say how you doing ma'am that
one guy got down on his knee to my ear
goes how you doing little lady thank you
for coming to see me and literally you
see like the women like oh my like
Jasmine she was like you know you don't
respect me you need to start respecting
me you never take hat yes she was like I
saw she was texting all her friends
talking to her mom on the way home about
like she like they were like every woman
was like melting cuz the Cowboys take
their hat off they're like how you doing
ma'am right you know and I was like oh
my God I got to start doing it and then
it's funny cuz you got guys like the new
school guys wear like these hockey
goalie helmets but then the old school
guys just do it in a cowboy hat just do
it old school no were little sign on the
neck that say kick me kick me and you
know what's crazy United States like
we're like it's mostly done here but you
know what where do you think if you had
to guess what's the the other big
country that produces the most number
one bull riders Spain Brazil ah Brazil
Brazil they're biger at Brazil but I
mean dude if or people out there if you
ever get a opportunity to go see
professional bull riding do it so
they're taken care of yes can you go
back to what you had up there before
Chone uh can we read that can I read
that go to the top you said it's
something said something like if you
think Bull's nuts a tied your own okay I
don't know let's see don't believe the
myth that bulls have their testicals
tied up because nothing could be further
from the truth here's what you need to
do said nine times stock contractor and
year CH take a rope tie it around yours
and pull it tight and see how high you
can jump that's basically what I was
told by this I might have actually been
talking to stock contractor of the Year
Chad burer he probably was at the event
and that's what I was talking to it is
tied around the Bull's flank oh not
their nuts contrary to PO the flank
strap is not tied around the Bull's
testicles the rope is to encourage the
bull to use his hind legs more in a
bucking motion as this is the true test
of the r skill so then so then so I'm
sorry so then who's going around
spreading the rumor that they nuts are
tied and then who is believing it if
it's not true like why do we all why do
every one of us believe the nuts are
tied I think it's I think it's it's more
more propaganda from Big
Bull it is it's [__] is what it is
yes how how do I protect my balls from
bull riding don't get on wear a cup
that's so funny some bull go ahead baby
some bull riders may use specialized
protective gears such as padded shorts
or groin cups to help protect themselves
during the intense and physical
demanding sport of bull riding the thing
that they told us about too when they're
in that little pen before they come out
the bull which is 1,700 lb is rocking
its weight back and forth crushing the
rider's knees and thighs against the
against the thing so the whole sport is
pain you cannot get through that sport
without being in pain even if even the
most perfect rides when they Dismount
like they that bull is throwing you off
it is throwing and then it was funny how
some bulls have personalities like some
Bulls would throw a cowboy off and then
it would just do a lap around MSG and
then run back into the thing and then
some balls would just some balls would
just be bucking as they're running back
in and then there's like a cowbo Curts
there's a cowboy on a horse there's a
cowboy on a horse that's standing there
if any of these Bulls get out of control
after they throw right off the cowboy
comes around and tries to lasso the bull
and there's a 1700 lb bull a 1700 lb
bull the cowboy will come in with the
lasso and try to get the bull and
there's a lot but the horse just thinks
the Bulls are playing so the horse every
time this bull comes out the Cowboys
trying to hold the horse back cuz horse
just wants to go start messing around
with the bull I tell you right now this
it's unbelievable this whole thing
sounds like a insurance nightmare oh
yeah I mean a liability in a half but
you're liable for for for the kids to
see a cowboy get his his head knocked
off his shoulders I don't think can you
Google has anyone ever been killed in
profession in PBR I don't think I think
that they keep it pretty safe these guys
are professionals call p i call PBR I um
but it was literally one of those events
that like I am going to follow it on
television it's and they have to hold on
with one arm and you get more points if
you can throw your leg off the side of
the bull to demonstrate how much control
you have like how much this bull don't
got [__] on you you gain more points
yeah it's basically like step like it's
B like you know it's Bally like see
here's the thing many people died so
he's the third guy many people died well
loow was the third guy he said that died
oh he was well known for being a cowboy
and uh in 2018 uh they lived in the
Missouri with their dog Gator and they
had to his death there in the 19 uh he
died okay God bless him heh so what
happen did they shut down the rest of
the night if somebody dies I would
imagine yeah but I mean he didn't nobody
died at Ms years old Jes but you do see
that the way these Bulls are kicking
like I'll show you more videos I'll send
them to Steve remind me I'll send them
so we could so the fans could see it
literally like even even when you're
watching it you're like if they even the
people who are trying to Wrangle the
bull after they throw the CBO I'm like
one of these guys gets kicked in the
face so what they do is they try to like
fake the bull out and have the bull
charge them and then it charges right
back into the pen yeah how do you get
into this you got to be born into it I
think that I mean all these guys are
from Oklahoma do the bull have cute
names like dorham or John Claude Van
they all have different they all those
are no there was one I there was one
bull um they have like the some of the
names sounded like porn names go at the
PBR bull names one of them was like I
think one of them name was Lexington
Steel
bushwhacker j31
Bodacious 61 little yellow jacket right
yeah be the north 825 big ugly seven War
dance okay so these are why they why
they have numbers they got power ratings
yes oh wow and the way it works is you
you get randomly put with your bll look
at that bll war Dan is a power rating of
95 when these other bulls have 68 78 wow
yep strong like bull strong like bull
these Bull and when you see let me ask
you a question too I don't know if you
guys know this or if you never thought
about this like a bull right that's just
a male cow
right like a bull is a male cow is that
that's right so so
every we might to talk about this every
single burger we eat is a female cow is
a female cow and every piece of steak I
think you're every milk every I think
you're only ever eaten the females is
that true every Burger I've ever eaten
has always been female glass of milk and
burger is all from a woman fale female
cow the future is female is that true I
think that's true cuz I bus are male
cows right yeah I don't know a lot about
animals I got to tell you I don't know
what they are actually what's you know I
don't know the difference between a ram
a goat a sheep I know difference between
any horses a hamburger is typically made
from ground beef which comes from
various cuts of a cow but is the cow
always female oh do we eat male or
female cows go to people people also ask
down down down here we
go
but all C it says beef can be made from
either male or female cattle for breeds
explicitly raised for beef like Angus or
herfords all calvs are reared for meat
regardless of sex increasingly Cows and
Bulls of the Holstein breed born on
dairy farms are inserted into the beef
production system but my question is is
then what's a bull Isn't a bull doesn't
a bull have sex with a cow to make more
cows or is a bull are there male bulls
and female Bulls are there female Bulls
young Bulls steers which are castrated
blls and heers which are young females
can all be used in beef production
they're slaughtered at different ages
and weights depending on what the buyers
want I don't know man it just feels like
like like I forgot that a heer was a was
a yeah that's a like a bull so like I
kind of felt like like were the Bulls
female then at the PBR or were they male
I didn't want to ask this guy all those
questions cuz he already looked at me
like I wasn't a man right right right
right like he couldn't believe like that
I didn't even know anything oh you think
female Bulls are bucking as well I think
so
huh well I mean how long you think you
last on one on a on seriously one second
cuz also the body's not meant to do that
either when they last when you're
watching them and they're on there and
they got they have to hold on tight but
the rest of their body's got to be like
jello and their body's like just ripping
around like they have to have like I
don't even know how you How do you what
is the regimen like what is the workout
process for that to like you know Excel
but also limit injury like how do you
what do you do for your body to make it
be you can be whipped Every Which Way
without ripping something off getting
Whiplash like what do they do do they
just like do a lot of break dancing I
think they do break they're RI they're
all relatively small framed guys but
they need to also be very um what's the
word I'm looking for like they have to
be very not agile but like they have to
be flexible yeah yeah they they they
have to have a lot of elasticity
elasticity elasticity and they I maybe
they do a bunch of yoga but I I don't
think that these Cowboys are doing yoga
well maybe they should maybe that's the
secret well that the thing is too with
them is like you know they're traveling
doing this all the time you know like
like they like the like here like there
was this one guy took a video of them
like these are the type of people that
they are like he was just like he
couldn't believe that like you know like
the New York Pizza like there these guys
are like from like the middle of nowhere
you know down south where is this guy
does the bull that kill somebody does he
keep riding like does he still keep his
job they can't kill the bull right
because that's his this is bware own
your ride the bull at your own risk I
mean you can't you can't put the bull
down it's not like a dog what did you
want the bull to do right you you you
asked for the bull to do this the bull
did his job okay the bull did his job no
yeah like look at this just a sweet kid
no
[Applause]
teeth just giggling overalls like you
know they're just like he was like hey
I'm just down here Happ luck happy go I
never been in New York City um but yeah
that's right they can't kill the bull if
they kill the rider right and but does
the bull still live to does the bull
still act like do does he live to Buck
another day
correct stop there Buck could stop there
it
depends it depends I mean the buck stops
there um that might be the reason why
that might be where the saying comes
from the buck stops there oh maybe
interesting I was I was on a I went to a
dude ranch for like seventh grade and
they put me on a horse that started to
Buck I told you this I was scared out of
my goddamn life and uh the the horse was
going on two legs in the air like and
then down on one leg and kicking going
back up again I was in seventh grade
never been on a horse before in my life
and never been
since I have been again since but it
would took a while but I'm screaming and
I got real scared and then the Cowboys
there were not gentlemen I told you I
might have told you the story before the
guy came over and like well we quit
you're yapping he's like quit quit
yelling you're making it worse I'm a I'm
a seventh grade child on a bucking horse
for the first time in my life and then
they came over and like they calmed them
down at first they like didn't think
that it was a big deal like it was it
went up and down twice and I looked
around like and they looked at me and
didn't say anything and I was like is
anyone going to acknowledge the fact
that I'm a child on this thing and then
and I was like help like like what's
going on like ah I might have started
crying I don't know and then they came
and calm down the guy scolded me because
it goes hot right it was a goddamn horse
bucking up it was going up on his legs
and everything and then they they they
they calmed him down and then they
scolded me for yelling and making it
worse and then they got me on another
horse I told you the horse's name was
like glue stick or something and they
put the horse is literally you know how
you sit on it his like his back was like
inverted it was like sloping down this
like old horse and I got on him and he
walked over to a tree and he started
eating the tree and wouldn't move after
that and then and like everyone went and
I just was sitting on this horse that
wouldn't move on the tree he was like
ready to die though was Biggie just
eating the tree and you didn't get to
see anything but that tree I I I I think
they finally got him to move but I did
not partake like the rest of the people
like he just meandered how he wanted and
he didn't respond to anything he the
exact opposite that that other horse and
I really think I got a raw deal there do
you know horses were not native to the
United States the Spanish came and when
they invaded the United States they just
left the horses here in the wild horses
that they're not supposed to be here how
many horses could they have brought that
they they pought a lot of horses cuz
horses be then yeah oh my god dude you
you horses Google horses you never seen
never watch a hor I don't know yeah they
go at it
right oh they have animal videos I don't
know don't like him click this one oh
yeah don't click it don't click it you
already Googled but that is interesting
where there's a site that says animal
well like it's like but only for Animals
I never even thought about that this
thing horse with horse compilation of
hot no but they're talking about women
wait wait but I think what they're doing
is they're taking horses that are having
because they need to have to make horses
and live and I think they're filming it
and then they just and I think they're
just buying a domain I don't think the
horses think that they're having no but
I think but just based off the
description I think that this is them
having with women cuz this one says this
one says Oh I thought it was two horses
having well cuz this one description is
horse drills young wild
beast real POV
stallion what is that what is that wait
you're going to have to beep a bunch of
this because because the uh we keep a
clean show no because we have to do like
a yeah interesting yeah I mean yeah some
of that we got we can't like cuz cuz
that cuz now they're saying like the
things reading the transcripts and it's
like oh yeah all right all right yeah
yeah right now I mean I
don't care cuz we want cuz we said this
was a clean Pol but no I don't care if
it clean but I just don't want to lose
money no I don't want to lose money
either I think like yeah yeah it might
it might deter you
know it might deter like a toothbrush
company from Hell fresh is in no matter
what we
do hell fresh whoever runs that that guy
is just he's awesome that is matter of
fact it's like he's like they got Bol
Tesco recipes on that thing yeah free
breakfast for
life um so let's not click on that let's
not click on it but dude do yourself a
favor go to professional bull riding
they do it every year at Madison Square
Garden the first the first event usually
of the new year is professional bull
riding at msj okay next year we're
in we we should go you know what we did
one time I used to had the podcast
called uh what say you a Q and we used
to do trips with the with our audience
so we went to go see Gallagher one year
we also went to where the hell did we go
we went to see uh uh Fast and Furious
you know like and literally like we had
like aund couple hundred listeners come
and we went and did it Clash trip right
we should do you guys take like a bus
there or something no we just met
everyone there right you know and then
uh yeah so we met everyone at the
theater we met everyone to you know and
it was it was awesome let's do a hey
babe class trip to professional bull
riding next year for real it is it is an
unbel and it's funny because you'll have
like real New York like grease balls
wearing cowboy hats yeah we'll like pick
a section yes and we'll tell everyone to
get tickets in that SE the bab section
and then we'll maybe we'll meet like at
a like at a bar right outside the garden
for like a half an hour before and we'll
walk over with them it'll be a blast and
we'll have Steve playing the drums we'll
have Steve playing we'll have him around
with the one around his his do you ever
do that the one around your neck like
you like you're a little pie Piper the
drummer boy whatever never did the
marching band okay what a great first
episode by Steve I yeah I mean I you
know great I I I just I I'm I'm very
excited to see how cuz you know you know
obviously this is going to be a change
of of a Dynamic cuz it's a new person
sitting here and I know that you know
our our our audience you know three
years with pimpy and I know that some
people might be like oh yeah we got to
take some getting used to well I tell
you we're coming hot out of the gate
here hot out of the gate and and Steve
has just told us he motioned to me that
this entire episode he's had his
testicles tied up and that's the kind of
dedication we're talking he didn't even
say anything for the whole episode and
that's the kind of dedication you can
expect from Stevie Chone the phone
rone this is a beginning of a great
thing you're a bucking Legend a boy the
Jabron yes you are and uh and yeah I
mean just uh yeah I'm excited and and
what I like really what I like is that
he he knows the show he told me he was a
listener of the show for for a long time
so he knows what we do here beautiful he
knows what we're about Steve knows what
we're about yeah and DM us if you if you
want to get uh if you want to get in
Steve's pants this is the way to do it
this is how we're going to start this
off he cuz he is a single guy he's a
single man he is a one of the sweetest
men I've ever met I about him and his
family he's a Family Guy stand up guy
with Integrity yep and uh he's a hard
worker this man comes from R cona my
friend Ron cona baby cona to hear to
hear and he's like no big deal I'm I
wouldn't do it n he does all right boys
this been he babe it's been hey
babe